[Music]
welcome to I'm Rhett and I'm Linc
thank you for allowing us into your ears
your minds your hearts and your eyeballs
if you're watching on YouTube under this
is mythical Channel oh I relished this
time Rhett where you and I get to just
speak with one another at this dimly lit
table
I noticed you interestingly you're such
a creature of habit but you've made the
definitive choice to not say you don't
like to say when it's just the two of us
you don't like to say this week at the
round table of dim lighting which is
very interesting because you used like
to do things exactly the same way well I
made a choice though because if you're
not doing it I know you've made like
I've thought about yeah I'm not gonna
say it I'm gonna say it a different way
yeah I meant to talk to you explain
yourself that is a relic of the old way
that we did here biscuits where it was
very strictly guests related so there
was an assumption someone is joining us
this week at the round table of dim
lighting blam and now it's just as
likely to be us as it is somebody else I
don't know I'm not gonna run the numbers
I think not technically but not
technically but mentally for me when I
sit down at this table like I said your
mental process now I relish just being
able to like hash the relish with you my
friend may I suggest something that you
may suggest anything you want helps to
my obligated which is interesting
interesting because I'm usually the one
that would be yeah who cares about
tradition Stickley your stick learning
but I have a different perspective on
this because I love the phrase so much I
just feel like you you I think the part
that you didn't like correct me if I'm
joining us you don't like that part so
you're like you don't like saying this
week at the round table of dim lighting
joining us yeah it's and I never I don't
need us yet I never say joining that's
to you that's you brother I never say
joining I don't say it anymore
I always say this week at the round
table of dim lighting and then we have
to say it's just the two of us so it
sounds like an apology whereas it should
be but you I think you're throwing the
base the base you
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
because not to get too critical but what
you were saying I don't think was
working and then way you came back to
the round table of dim lighting and you
tried to slyly slip it in
oh just now when you conversation you
came back to it and you want you want
here's what you want you want to keep as
a standard they can count on a reference
to the round table of dim landing yeah
and I think maybe you know what I
respect that on the tables moving I'm
gonna take this opportunity while retz
faces away from the microphone to make
an executive decision that I am going to
say and I'm linked this week at the
round table of dim lighting we're gonna
blank yeah that's my idea exactly that's
what I was thinking all the lots where I
was headed with that so as long as we
say that I'm gonna find listen let's try
again let's drop the whole thing let's
roleplay I don't really care try it but
I was just trying I was surprised that
you wanted to change it cuz you usually
don't like to change things so it's just
like what's he thinking so that's one of
the probe in your mind but now we're
going back to the old way pry he pried
it no we're not going back to the old
way we're testing out the new way turn
welcome to welcome to ear biscuits I'm
red and just to clarify you were already
welcomed this is a role play so don't be
confused we're welcoming you again go
again I'm sorry
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table a
dim lighting we got lots of good stuff
to discuss but I don't even know what it
is that's good yeah I know it's good of
course we shouldn't even comment on how
good it is we should just move on as if
that's good
we just meant to do it right you're
doing it right now link you did you did
it right that time to quote a seat line
from season 2 a buddy system oh yeah I
feel so much more acquainted with this
table and this configuration because
over the past couple of weeks we put a
lot of hours in these chairs recording
the audio book for the book of
mythicality
that will be available on audible.com I
just got a book of mythicality calm for
all the details for pre-ordering but a
lot of people ask questions because I
posted a picture of us recording and
they were like how's your voice because
I share my having voice troubles you
know what I made it through there was
only a couple of times where there was
like a crack in my voice and I had to
start over that's that's what's
happening when it happens is there's
like a crack in the voice only happened
like a handful of times and I my voice
hurt a little bit than today but I don't
think I sounded any different I think
I'm gonna sound pretty much the same way
throughout the book like slightly sick I
think you yeah I think you sounded at
one point I was like can you Reese a
that whole paragraph because you sounded
like you had just woken up yeah without
I did what you don't understand is that
I did that on purpose I thought that
would be a nice effect but just woken up
effect but you didn't like it so I
changed it just like you know that's out
that's how this partnership works I
think well we'll talk more about how
excited we are about the audible version
of the book when when you can actually
purchase and listen to it yeah in well
it's not that far off mid October mid
October so it's not that far off this
thing we're gonna have this big launch
of the book but I can confidently say
given the special guests who read the
parts that they wrote in our book given
their appearances it's it's all more
exciting that you're gonna have to buy
the physical book preorder it now and
you're gonna have to get the audio book
because they're two distinct experience
they are they're very complimentary but
they are they are exclusive in many ways
oh it was nice to read back to the book
and remember everything we wrote our
wives set at this table mm-hmm our wives
sat here in read the parts of the book
that they wrote I don't know if we've
told you guys we we have we have told I
can't remember what we told you you
really wanted to hold on to that one for
a long time I mean to me that's the best
thing about the book is that we didn't
write part of it our wives just say it
like seven times not just once that's
all I'm saying then we'll say it again
yeah it's like when you got a movie
coming out and you're like why did hold
on why did that teaser trailer come out
seven months ahead of time because why
not be excited now and then
it can't be too excited about something
can you and our wives did a great job
they did they're great readers we
completely literate I think we both
stepped out for the other person's wife
to come in and take I give Jessie my
seat Chris you took your seat and it was
like okay we don't need too many cooks
in the kitchen and that's like as we
were reading as Chrissy was reading her
part because I'm giving some direction
I've given my opinion on I was about
this I was bottom okay so I'm interested
in how that was written we have a little
risky but I discuss that we could I mean
we could have gotten in a huge fight
because it's like I'm very comfortable
in this situation and I'm directing
directing my wife is a dangerous thing
in general we got to watch the table
here cuz this is happening here Cody's
gonna put his finger under the table for
the next hour ago we got it is it a
pinkie finger or a big toe what are you
putting under there it looks like his
whole hand just be still
there's two types of people in the world
there's people who go to a restaurant
and sit at a wobbly table and don't do
anything about it and then there's
people who get the napkin fold it up and
correct the problem what kind of person
are you
that's late that's laden with judgment
my friend I did I think I celebrate the
people who can just Zen out at a wobbly
table I am NOT one of those people you
know what I found to be in the hate the
role reversal I'm behaving like you
today I wanted it to be the same way I
fixed the wobbly table yeah what's up
you're like but you know what it was you
were the one that was this is this is
what was happening you were the one who
was watch my freaking phone I was
wobbling it you'd be all over it man no
I know what it is is the vasectomy oh
you're not wobble sensitive anymore I
think our personalities melded and we
each got a piece of each other I think
what happened is they did something to
your balls and it's like they did
something to your like to your cochlear
your cochlea or whatever that thing in
the inside of your ear is an icicles not
in my ear bro no though we were there no
the way male Scents wobbling is by the
testes and so that's why there's to your
wobble says it's it's like a city
comparison thing it's a minor completely
relative I was completely set maybe even
more so more sensitive to wobbling and
you lost wobble since
when they screwed the doctor Messam know
you gotten some of me you're acting odd
I wasn't that close to you you had you
admitted it you're being a little
neurotic today do you think he put part
of your vast difference in my scrotum
that's exactly what I'm saying
Keiko was there that didn't happen did
it he they owned the whole thing then
you didn't see that
Ben put up a black shield that then
Keiko stood behind I was like is this
like a splatter shield but it was so if
you tilted the camera down it wouldn't
it wouldn't show our junk like if you
got if you like fell asleep and you saw
it in a couple of shots like a blurry
sort of like it looked like the matte
box on the camera was kind of creeping
into the frame that was not the matte
box that was the splatter guard yeah
splatter guard it's one way to sneeze
guard well it it was it was the ball
paint guard I didn't know if something
was gonna splatter since we're talking
about the vasectomy we should and we you
know we're turning it into entertainment
left right and every whichaway
we should just keep doing that okay um
I'm I'm in recovery still I don't know
it was Friday Friday we're recording
this basically six days out from their
surgery and I wish I had I had to ice
last night oh you brought up the piece
and then what I mean ice creates
shrinkage which then keeps everything in
place more and I'm just being real here
that like I'm and I'm wearing the
tightest pair of underwear I have today
because I'm your kids yeah I'm wearing
some Lando's underwear got Superman on
it's what kids are for Superman's
cradling my mine my mouth let's not talk
about the procedure anymore I mean you
can watch that I just want to talk about
because we didn't talk about in good
mythical more where we talked a little
bit about the recovery I like we haven't
discussed what you we did because the
weekend I went home right after the
Friday afternoon we both go home yeah
and we have been told by other men who
had had this procedure done
keep taking it easy is really important
we actually didn't we didn't even we've
got together to work a little bit on
Monday but we didn't come into the
office and do a regular work they like
we typically would do because we were
told those first two days is crucial
even if you feel okay you need to keep
wearing the scrotal support this very
special pair of underwear actually
wearing them right now and yeah you need
to went back to went back to it I was
like I just feel like I need the extra
support today I threw mine away cuz they
were stained oh gosh
this is too much man this is too much
okay and you can also get new ones they
sell them at like Walgreens I'm not
walking any nice and mad send somebody
in to send your wife in cuz this you
know cuz they know it's not for her I
was meant for her I was very much
looking forward to it was kind of a
silver-lining thing like okay I'm not
gonna be comfortable I'm gonna have
frozen peas which is by the way the best
technique because ice melts peas stay
there they just get warmer and they also
can and those are the size of the peas
they can mow they conform to whatever
you need so as a silver lining and
knowing that I wasn't gonna be able to
do much I was focusing on not being
allowed to do much like my family was in
agreement
I had a somebody in our neighborhood let
us borrow their electric recliner for
Lily's recovery from back surgery we
have not given it back and so I was like
I'll give it back after this because I'm
gonna be in that recliner I'm gonna have
a recliner time I'm gonna be like a
grandpa I'm gonna stick in that recliner
with my frozen peas and every frickin
remote just laid out there this recliner
has a tray this isn't them that's a part
of it but the back room the back part
with the big television yeah in
point-blank range and I'm just gonna sit
there and I'm gonna do nothing and
everybody understands that and I'm not
gonna no one's gonna put me on a guilt
trip like when I'm on the toilet on my
phone for 30 minutes you know it's like
you know what you're doing dad and dad
makes they're on the phone about what's
on the television and I'm that was what
that was
was rule number one I was like I'm not
watching anything with you guys that was
a bit I did not make that clear and that
was a big problem oh yeah clear up front
right off the bat a big mistake on my
part I should have put a sign on the
door and then locked it just like
daddy's watching daddy shows that's what
I said kids close your doors the kids
guilted me and it like well I let him
watch part of the Dark Knight Batman
Begins hold on you watch Batman Begins
that was one of your choices no it was
with the kids one Friday night oh we
were watching something as it as a
family and it's like you want to watch a
good wholesome movie Batman Begins
Christopher Nolan kids you got her you
got to start learning this stuff right
and so we're watching it and we didn't
finish it and it said then the next day
they insist on watching the rest of the
movie with me which I didn't want to
happen but I was guilty dude you started
daddy time with the kids that's how it
started what you saw yes yes this is
supposed to be a daddy time meaning
alone time yeah me time me time I
finally got rid of them I hope it's good
for you cuz I'm just getting my bad
stuff out of the way okay okay then I'm
like all right now you kids go away I'm
sitting here with my peas and I'm gonna
watch the Defiant ones on HBO
this is dr. Dre and Jimmy Iovine
documentary I heard great things about
it one of my favorite things to watch is
a music documentary I love hip-hop dr.
Dre doesn't grant a lot of interviews I
heard this was like very revealing so I
was very intrigued my one of my favorite
things to watch on a screen is a is a
rap documentary okay super excited I
can't get to HBO go
it does a p-- on my television will not
work I don't understand it's so freaking
slow I'm like well maybe it's maybe it's
just this file I'm gonna go to like John
Oliver and so then I start watching that
and it's creeping along and I'm like
well go over to Netflix I'm like maybe
it's my internet I I got up I'm plugged
my I plugged my router
oh gosh you do that you gotta unplug the
router then you gotta unplug the
what's the what's the Internet the Wi-Fi
disk your unplug the modem and router
young you unplug the mode of an
employment background in that order you
count to 15 you plug the one back in 145
is that without the particle counter 45
I counted to 15 I plugged the modem and
away I count to another 15 and I plug in
the router and then I go all the way
back in there and then I well I I got to
restart the television - oh yeah I'm
jangling my testicles all over the house
this is defeating the purpose of
everything right sit back down
put on the Defiant ones nothing shame
nothing changed I'm like I'll go over to
Netflix Netflix working great yeah
Netflix is very reliable YouTube working
great Amazon Prime working great I got
it all baby except the one thing that
has the one thing I want to see and it's
so slow then I go I'm like you know what
I have it on cable cuz I still pay for
cable which is stupid I think except now
it's like whoo i'ma get you you can also
do this on me now HBO oh I tried that
and I was like I'll just watch it on my
laptop didn't work I ended up going to
on-demand on my cable box which you know
how frustrating using cable I'm afraid
of that whole system is just stupid
archaic it's like a railroad and then it
started working I this had to have been
an hour and a half later it literally
took that long to get to this man I feel
bad for you daddy time didn't start it
off real nice for me and then and then
Christie had to do some stuff so Lando's
around and he's it's a good thing that
he doesn't like screens so it's just
like to be occupied he has to be like
playing games and doing stuff but he
wanted to do that with me and I felt bad
so I was like I'll play a game with you
in the room but I'm gonna watch Defiant
once so here I am I'm like I could do it
all and then I'm like it dawns on me
very quickly after like it's not
appropriate dr. Dre just speaking freely
yeah it's not appropriate to in front of
my seven-year-old so I told him that I
was like this isn't appropriate for you
but we'll finish the game and then a few
seconds later I'm like no this is not
gonna work
you're gonna have to leave so he doesn't
just start watching what's on the screen
if he's in the room with it no it was it
was a documentary talking ahead okay I
mean Shepard though Shepard has a
problem he's got a screen problem so I
don't care what it was man Hellraiser
doesn't matter he's gonna immediately
lock on it and Lena doesn't have that
yeah absorbing well forget it
no Shepard had it from Age 3 well I
guess I'm I think it's a personnel doing
for the record I did not let Lando
listen to the Defiant ones with me for
more than a few seconds more than just a
few a few F bombs were dropped and then
you yeah he's had it quota
yeah he's get him out of the room but I
mean we've we've talked very
specifically about what we think about
those words and what's the most
important thing in life and those words
are for dr. Dre son that's what you say
yeah until you are a successful rapper
you can't see instead just focus on love
and kindness I did not go the
documentary route well first of all I
made it very clear I mean I made it
clear days maybe weeks ahead of time I
was like want to let you guys know heads
up and you you know how my house is and
it's like it's very open and so like
even a living room is open yeah so we
don't have like a place where you can go
into a room and close the door and watch
television there's like pedestrians
coming through your yeah living read
some busy place and so I had to be
really clear I was like daddy
it's daddy time daddy got his balls
operated on and daddy's needs some time
to himself to recover okay kids
daddy want to watch tea daddy don't want
no more y'all won't run around here
that's why daddy got this operation
leave daddy alone for a weekend so I
made that very clear now it worked with
the kids but my wife was really the
problem oh and not not that I care that
my wife is I mean I love having my wife
around well I'm watching television the
problem is is that she was so busy
having to leave and go here and there
and she started getting into the things
that I was watching and then asking me
to stop it pause it stop that and watch
something else so
was the only that was the only
interruption the daytime what I did is I
just caught up on a lot of series that I
wanted to watch on Netflix I finished
friends from college that new comedy
that's got Kiki Michael key in it which
there's a lot of mixed reaction to that
I liked it I liked it
thought it was funny and I finished that
pretty quickly but she kept making me
Paul's that cuz she's watched a little
bit of that with me and I just
remembered in the middle of my not in my
Defiant ones thing the reason why I took
an hour and a half was cuz I gave up and
not and because you told me that I
started watching that but then the kids
were coming in and out and that wasn't
appropriate either no kids can't then I
switched back made a kids stay in their
rooms for that one then the thing is she
would leave and then when she left I had
to watch narcos because I've been
watching Wyatt for a while and she won't
watch she's not interested in it and so
then I'm switching between English
English oh and a Spanish show I'm all
confused so then she comes back and I
had to stop Pablo Escobar in his tracks
and then immediately begin watching Kiko
Michael Keaton
keegan-michael key again and that was
problematic but I finished that series
and then I was like I'm gonna watch the
second season of master of none because
I haven't watched any of that hold on
you you watched all of friends from
college I'd already seen the first five
episodes with nark how many more
episodes were there five you watched
five more episodes of friends from
college I did nothing but watch
television for every day and then you
watched narcos in between that yeah and
then you went over and you watched
master of none the whole second season
and I'm not done yet are you kidding me
no I mean link I've told you everything
I saw I saw episode I saw half of
episode two of Defiant ones
oh my god that's why you were in more
pain than me man i daddy laid on his
butt on the couch with his balls and a
special cradle that the doctor gave him
and in binge watch TV till I was blue in
the face well I did some work too I like
gave notes somebody says I did too I
watched yeah you did work just because I
said I don't work I watched episode 203
and gave notes and then 204 had no audio
so I didn't watch that I also don't know
what else that did first of all master
none everybody's like
master of none season two masterpiece
it's like I was like oh okay come on now
really really I'm angry now now watch it
and I just especially watching it just
in the binge format just like letting
literally I I passively let each episode
just roll to the next one like the
counter says next episode in five
seconds I just let it happen
did you have a catheter in I got it to
be a couple of times but it's so good
man there there are problems like you
noticed like in season one of Master and
done you're like the acting is kind of
distracting but because the acting is
distracting in buddy system I'm willing
to forgive it you know because when you
watch yourself act and you watch
comedians actually Oh if this isn't this
is I'm not watching this for Oscars
Emmys to be awarded for Best Actor I'm
watching this because it's so well done
and written and it's interesting the way
to explore things I loved it loved
season 2 then better than season one
that much better
yes
so I actually stopped watching season
one I remember I got most of the way
through it I enjoyed it but season two I
was just like BAM I'm going all the way
through then I moved all you were doing
though to Ozark yeah and I'm like seven
episodes deeper even heard of this one
that's a Jason Bateman oh I that one has
like a very cold tint on the the
thumbnail has a crow I don't I don't
watch things where people are tinted
blue and there's a crow oh really
it's I want to watch I want to watch Dre
get real okay what my assessment of
Ozark thus far is it dark or sad it
looks sad and dark it's I don't need
that model it's a poor man's Breaking
Bad that's what it is it's you know
white-collar straight-laced dude gets
involved in drug crimes and jason
bateman jason bateman but so I wouldn't
say that in any Oh has like the
straight-laced wife and the kids try it
but it's basically Breaking Bad told in
a different way not as compelling I'm
sure he would appreciate that but I mean
listen that story I mean that story is a
story that can be told multiple times
I mean I'm seven episodes deep I like
the show
and now actually last night I got my
wife to come in and I did this you don't
typically do this but I was like I
really want to watch this so let me give
you the quick rundown on what happened
in the first six episodes like I'm the
Netflix catch you up thing personally
like your personal this is what happened
this is what you need to know can you
start watching episode seven with me and
she was like okay and we watched it and
she was into it so uh yeah IIIi ingested
all kinds of entertainment and some
painkiller but not a lot I didn't take
any pain killer either I just took the
ibuprofen I missed I don't all of it I
just don't know how to do potato sack
what's it called potato couch couch
potato potato sack that's a race man
sack race I don't know how to do sack
races guys okay well we're gonna
continue talking about some other
important things including the reaction
to us putting the vasectomy video on the
Internet
but first we want to let you know that
you were running out of time to be a
part of the tour of mythicality we've
added matinee shows in New York and Los
Angeles and New York would be at the
PlayStation theater on Saturday October
14th at 1:00 p.m. and then we're gonna
be at The Wiltern in LA on Sunday
November 5th at 12 p.m. so these are I
mean 12 p.m. that's not even matinee
that's just noontime that's just the
middle of the day but you go to tour
mythicality calm get the tickets while
you can they are selling fast and again
this is the last chance you have to see
the Tour of mythicality
in 27 alive in a live version also go to
mythical dot store to prefer to support
our internet Ament you can get the ear
biscuits mug the one we drink out of
when we're speaking here feel like
you're at the roundtable of dim lighting
with this jar I called it a mug but it's
a jar it is a jar doesn't need it's made
of hardened biscuit batter mythical dot
store lots of great stuff there and no
matter how hard you squeeze it it does
not break okay now so we as you know Oh
you know we we documented the entire
process of us getting a vasectomy and
we've known for a while that we were
going to do this there's lots of
questions like why would you guys do
this why would you document it well
we've said it for a long time that if we
ever go through the through the process
of getting a vasectomy we're going to
document and put it on the Internet and
yes for entertainment purposes for views
yes that's why we did it but also as you
pointed out it gave you the motivation
to actually go through the procedure
knowing that you could do it for
entertainment purposes
well I'm altima Lee motivated for the
obvious reasons that any person would be
motivated but I was so P kid
which means faint of body fainted buddy
I just needed one more thing to push me
over the edge and that was hey the thing
I'm most scared about is going through
the process so it will help me to have
cameras there to have to focus my energy
of nervousness into entertaining you and
it helps a whole lot it helps so much I
mean yes I was still freaking out I had
to get the freakin Demerol shot but um I
I couldn't I could not I would have been
freaking out a lot more I think it makes
me think then internally I want to have
all my medical procedures documented I
think I need this comfort well I think
we've done it I think we've committed to
it okay I mean given the other medical
procedures we've already talked about on
air biscuits I'm glad that we've made
the decision now yeah but I think you
you've been tracking more closely
audience reaction to this thing that I
have I I watched the video with my
family the the morning it came out I
read a few comments but that was it and
we I I I I laughed a whole lot and I was
very happy with the final product
yeah I loved the music how the music was
incorporated and I know you you and
Stevie worked with Casey on on that
yankin in succession yeah it was one of
those sort of a old-school you know we
haven't done that in a while we haven't
gone out and
done something and document it and put
it on the show so I was happy to step in
and get involved in the Edit but what
are people saying what was well first of
all we could devote an entire podcast to
answering continued misconceptions
lingering misconception as to what
happened you know people who think we
got our balls cut off even though they
saw I think all the procedures are these
people who watched good mythical more
cuz I don't want to rehash that stuff we
I'm just saying that that still is just
absolutely nuts and I don't and that was
not a pun intended usually say no pun
intended but I just said that was not a
pun intended but it was a pun I'm not
gonna talk about those misconceptions
but what I will talk about is the again
we talked about it we'd love to throw
things out there and sort of guess what
the audience reaction is gonna be and
before we release the video I was like
okay let's go ahead and just emotionally
prepare ourselves there's going to be a
lot of people who don't understand what
happened and why we're doing it lots of
people just just vomit out they're
ignorant about various subjects on the
internet and when you throw something
out like a vasectomy you're gonna get a
million people who just who do that that
happened but the other thing we're gonna
get is you guys have gone too far this
is officially too far right because
there's always this ongoing conversation
we talked about on your biscuits before
and we've been talking about it for as
long as we've been in business brother
people always thinking that we're
pushing the limits too far or that
somehow the line has moved and we've
gotten too close to it and now we've
officially crossed it so for a lot of
people it was you guys have done it I
can no longer let my kids watch this
show I actually saw one comment was like
my twelve-year-old daughter came to me
and told me that she can no longer watch
the show because of this episode and I'm
just gonna take this opportunity to
reiterate what we said before great good
for her that's great for you if you've
given your daughter that perspective and
that's the perspective that you want
your daughter to have daughter or son
kids and they came back and voiced that
to you and you feel good about it great
you're doing what you want with your
family good for you well I wouldn't say
great I believe that I just I would just
say okay okay
I don't okay it's great by saying great
I'm not hey I'm not saying that's the
way I do things in my house I
I think it's good for you but I love it
but we don't want to say well that's sad
we're not gonna render judgment against
someone seen this will cost across the
line for me so I'm not gonna watch it
where I'm not gonna allow someone in my
purview to watch it one of my kids or or
what not we are not going to say well
that's sad or that's this we're not that
we're not saying we're not gonna try to
hold on to you if you wonder if you go
to jail points if you are wondering
judgment we're not yeah we're not we're
not trying to keep you we're not also
judging you for for saying this isn't
for you yeah if you want to go if we you
think we cross a line and you want to
leave the herd leave the herd this is
not there's no we're not no one's
forcing you to do any of this and and
people think it's something that people
think the show something that it's not
yeah and I and III I that's why we
continue to talk about it just as by way
of Education but I will also say and has
the line moved a little bit maybe so of
course it has as as we've gotten older
as our kids have gotten older but what I
will say is that as we've said many
times before we don't do anything that
we don't let our kids watch link has a
seven-year-old son I have a
nine-year-old son we watched the video
with them and they laughed at everything
that we said all this talk about balls
all the jokes about our private parts
all the explicit not in terms of profane
but explicit talk about the private
parts that stuff that already happens in
our homes yeah I got two boys we talked
about balls all the time it's not just a
boy thing I mean I think I've seen but
lately they have balls yes so we end up
talking about the balls a lot I mean
lily has two younger brothers so she's
she's she's immune to testicular talk
it's just it's like breathing air in our
home
right you might breathe in a ball if you
if you if you don't watch out a ball
joke about joke we keep them we keep the
we keep them holstered man or i give
them a supportive scrotal support what's
the point you're trying to make the
point is is that we so far I'm not
saying we're
ever gonna create something that we're
like specifically hey this is just for
adults but what you will know is that it
will we will let you know that it's just
intended for adults if that's the case
because we're sensitive to who's
watching our videos but the the
barometer that we use personally is what
we would let our kids watch and so it
that definitely does kind of change but
I'm not saying one cycle they get they
get older so the line changes I don't
once they become adults I'm not saying
that once their kids are all grown up
that all of a sudden it's all for adults
at that point right because we
understand that the content that we
create is by our standards is
family-friendly that doesn't mean that
every family is going to find it
friendly but for what we see is family
friendly like everybody sits down all
ages sit down and enjoy
we still create that kind of stuff in
our house that means some ball jokes are
gonna fly around especially when you're
getting your balls operated on that's
and also another big part of what we did
we did the video was I do think it's
educational in spite of the fact that
people watch the videos and still think
that we've somehow lost our manhood I
can't help you if you that's the way
your brain works good luck in life I'm
sure you're gonna be okay but we're
probably not gonna have a productive
conversation about this okay okay okay
and we did put a warning at the begin to
video I mean it is an extraordinary
video so we said what it was gonna
contain and what it wasn't gonna contain
and then we then correct it said here's
the point where you can click away lots
of opportunities but I don't know why
you would then go to someone go to a
parent and then say so from now on I'm
not watching any of your videos because
they did this one where they warned me
at the top of it that I this particular
one is is more special so I'd that's a
little unfair to us yeah but we did and
so but we don't mind let let let it be
said I'm not deeply hurt do not care but
I can tell you though frustrate you know
your eyes widen no no people's dilate
I'm frustrated with people think people
thinking that we care that's the thing
that I do care about it's just like very
ironic yeah
there is a distinction it's just I just
want to be I want to be like if you
don't want to watch it and don't watch
it you don't have somebody I did see
somebody say listen this is not an
airport you don't have to announce your
departure I thought that was a great
line well yeah and they didn't make it
up either okay someone you know buddy's
grandeur you know you really you think
they'll think that was an original joke
okay no I'm gonna credit the person who
did here I've never heard anybody say it
either but I could hear that I can
believe that many granddad's have said
let's move along to other controversial
issues so I did it will have been over a
week maybe two weeks
by the time this this episode is up that
I that I did the thing that we're gonna
talk about now yeah you wrote a piece
I'll call it a people sees link you you
wrote a piece about your perspective of
the of the the Confederate monuments
coming down in the south or people's
opinion about those monuments coming
down or stained and yeah it's all my
Twitter it's it's it's a medium article
which by the way if you have familiar
with medium its I am NOT
it's basically a blogging platform where
you can look like you wrote an article
but it's great because always it's
aidable and wiki now it's it's
essentially a way to you know create an
article like put a picture in an article
and then it kind of goes into that
system but all you have to do is have
like a Twitter account or a Facebook
account or whatever to just have one and
then people can follow you so if I write
something else everyone who started
following me because the first article
can see the next one and that kind of
thing you can create series and that
kind of thing not a sponsor but it's a
blog but post post posing as an article
well what's really the difference in
2017 I would say that it's in other
words it's not curated or edit
editorialized by any one group it's
completely user based but it's presented
as articles and that's how you sort
through things and things are tagged and
you know related articles come up that
kind of thing people could comment so
it's called thoughts on Confederate
memorials from a white southern male I
think that's the name of it but it's on
my Twitter read em see you can see that
I tweeted it out now what led to this
I'm gonna talk a little bit about what
led to this because I'm gonna get into
the into the you can see what I thought
and what I said in the article well let
me give you the me give you the one
minute summary of what I said on the
article because I so you don't just
pause it and go read it yeah and I'll do
that and I'll say I I'm really
interested in I mean I've read the
article and I'm very engaged in that but
I'm also very interested in everything
that went around leading up to you
actually taking the time to write it as
busy as you are and the fact that I we
typically know everything that we're
gonna do when it's something like that
before it's done but like I think we
were working apart like a buddy system
and some different stuff I got home that
night and Chris she's like did you see
Reds article that he wrote I'm like
Rhett wrote an article yeah see it said
my first thought was well I didn't know
about this Rhett wrote an article I
didn't I didn't know what it there what
that's got an article business on the
side I didn't I didn't get to read it
until I was in bed that night and i read
it and i retweeted it i mean we can get
in it we can get your welcome we can get
any more thoughts about it but yeah go
to Octavia Spencer link but yeah I'm oh
I appreciate your time I'm interested in
the yes because it means more to me
Percy the tertiary story that led to the
thing because there's not much that
either one of us do that the other one
doesn't know about or find out about
through the internet that was just it's
just an interesting thing yeah so it's a
very short feelings we're not hurt it's
a very short post is very happy and it
basically says hey I grew up in the
south I grew up in a culture we're all
pretty much everyone everyone that I
knew believed very specific things about
the history of the Civil War and there's
there is very much a kind of a
glorification of the the southern calls
and not really stopping to stop and
think well what do
all the black people who live around us
think about this particular perspective
that we have that perspective being that
you know the Confederate generals were
good men and the Union generals were bad
men and the you know the the south it
wasn't any more racist than the north
and you know most importantly the Civil
War wasn't even about slavery it was
about states rights lots of things that
you're taught and so you kind of have
this perspective that oh well all the
stuff that you hear about in books and
stuff is wrong it's actually this that
and the other and and I'm nodding my
head because absolutely I heard all the
exact same things right I was in many of
the same conversations and so of course
when the the discussion of Confederate
memorials comes up there's lots of like
well this is erasing history that's what
that's what you keep hearing people are
erasing history and my point was is that
these monuments the vast majority of
these monuments they in themselves were
an effort to erase history because they
were themselves the glorification of the
Confederate cause many of them financed
by the Daughters of the Confederacy in
between the before the like 1895 to the
First World War and it was a movement in
the south which goes on to this day to
kind of venerate and honor the southern
calls and kind of rebrand what actually
happened and a lot of those monuments
were put up for those reasons so it's
totally understood now that people are
kind of offended by them because they're
they're not teaching history they're
honoring as they're rewriting the past
in many cases so my point was you're not
gonna dissemble racism by taking down a
monument and so I'm actually not like a
huge like hey I want to go out there and
rip these things down that's not what
I'm about but I understand which
literally happened in Durham North
Carolina but I understand that the
perspective and what I said is because
these things are symbols in the people
who put them up and financed them for
the vast majority of them they were
symbols of ultimately if you want to be
explicit about it hate right and saying
that White's owned and run the south
then bringing them down is at least
symbol
of saying that we're leaving that
perspective behind this is about history
so that was the point in the article but
why did I talk about this I'm a comedian
right what do I know first of all I'm
just a comedian over here in Los Angeles
on the left coast what why am i speaking
I don't care about your opinion the
reason I did this is in chose to do it
now and haven't spoken about any of
these things before
it was I kind of just got to a point
where I think you can only hear so many
things and feel so many things about
them and know that you do have a
platform and you do have a way to get
something out there into the world and
people will listen just because you have
a following and not say something you
can only last so long but specifically
what Lex is trying to eat away at you
was my wife has kind of been doing the
whole thing that I'm sure many of you do
and sort of having these Facebook
arguments about things right and like
what's neither one of us do because we
don't have face personal face I have a
Facebook account that I just used to
help manage the rhett and Link Facebook
account but it's not one that I used
personally but my wife has one and she's
a typical Facebook user so you look over
her shoulder right well she's well she's
just sitting there with her phone or her
computer and she's like this is what
this person said now and now I'm gonna
say this and she's very civil and very
smart and articulate in the way that she
communicates these things but she's
arguing with a bunch of people mostly
people back home in North Carolina who
have this perspective which was so many
people kept saying why are we erasing
history what's next are we gonna start
taking down statues of George Washington
and Abraham Lincoln where did they get
that line from yeah exactly and so I was
just like okay I can only where did he
get that line from I can only hear those
things so many times before I'm just
like can I just step in and give my
perspective because I first of all I
think it's very we have to be very
careful when you come into a situation
and you speak something into it you have
to take into account context and you
have to take into account who you are
and as a white southern man coming into
a situation
there is there's a lot of baggage that I
bring into any conversation right you
bring your baggage to the conversation
and so I wanted to come at it with a
listen this is the perspective that I
kind of bring to this based on my
background and how I've had to kind of
come overcome that perspective in some
way so I don't want to come in and be
like this is what you should think about
this but it was more this is my
experience and this is what I think now
and so I just want to kind of just speak
my mind hopefully in a way that will be
considered by people on both sides of
the spectrum and I really appreciated
that about your approach was that you
didn't say something every to your point
about baggage you you wrote about your
baggage I mean it was it was a
confessional in a lot of ways it wasn't
it wasn't first and foremost an opinion
piece I mean your your your opinions in
your perspective or definitely in there
but it was through the lens of this is
this is the baggage that I have mm-hmm
I'm gonna tell you about that I think in
in reading the the comments underneath I
mean you got to be signed in you got to
have a medium account and everything to
comment there so there's one a lot of
comments when I read through it that
night it's probably a lot more now but I
appreciated the tone of the conversation
that was having that was being had down
there even for some people who disagreed
but there were a lot of people who said
that they appreciated there were people
who would say I'm from England and this
feels where I'm from I can't remember
they said they were from but I'm from
blank not the United States and this is
this is such a foreign thing for me but
it's so helpful for me to to read it -
read your perspective as a person who
lived it this is like reading about your
baggage yeah or you know I in it it did
make me think when you were reiterating
it here it's like I remember when I
turned 16 and I got I got I was like I
got tapes
for my truck and it's like I got my new
Charlie Daniels Greatest Hits tape and
it's going through all these great
Charlie Daniels songs and then there's
one that's the South's gonna do it again
well do what again and I'm like I'm
singing along with this song and it's
like I love Charlie Daniels because of
the first nine songs on the on the tape
and then let's say that was the tenth
one of a greatest hits album by the way
this is not just a deep track this is
what they called it greatest hit the
South gonna do it again man I thought
that was a cool ass song and what about
Hank Williams jr. at the South woulda
won we have it made remember that one
yeah and it so you I mean this is the
world that we lived and breathed through
saying something saying these songs we
belted out these songs not understanding
what they meant never really starting to
think but it made me feel great
oh you felt great at the time yeah I
mean it because southern pride man
southern pride now I think but but dig
dig dig into it and what does it mean
yeah I think that's something the reason
that I spoke about this is that you know
we are not interested in being political
and we definitely when it comes to
something like good mythical morning
we're not interested in it having a
political perspective not saying that
we're not going to talk about political
figures or whatever but we don't have a
strong political perspective that kind
of you could pin the show down as having
because we want it to be very inclusive
and that actually translates into why I
talked about this is because I actually
don't think that this is a political
issue right I don't think that you have
to think a certain way about what's
going on in our country right now
because of your political party but
that's the way that we think we think
what is my party think what is my
platform what is the ideology that I
have committed myself to already that my
family and my friend and bio that I'm
committed and by party you don't
necessarily mean political part
you could mean any group or tribe
affiliation if you will but with this
issue there is yeah there is a pretty
stark contrast between you know your
political perspective based on your
party and I just think that doesn't make
any sense it's like I don't want to know
if you're a Democrat or a Republican I
don't want to know if you're a
progressive or a conservative because I
actually don't think that this is a
progressive versus conservative issue I
think this is just like what are we
trying to do what do we hope is going to
our future is going to be like like do
we want our future to be one of unity
oneness wholeness love I think 99% of
people would say yes of course you've
got those crazy white supremacists who
are who definitely don't want that
who they want the races to be separate
and they're very vocal about that but I
still think that while there's a lot of
racist undercurrent in our country and a
lot of people are racist even if they
don't know it there's only a few people
who are speaking that saying that
divisive rhetoric about how we should
not be whole and not be one and not be
unified but the problem is is that so
many people who if you just ask them a
question like do you want the country to
be more unified do you want people to
love each other more they would say yes
yes I want that but then they turn
around and say but I do not care enough
about what the black community thinks to
say I'm willing to let this statue come
down because of what it symbolizes in
our past a part of our past that we
don't want to forget but we don't want
to glorify we're not going to forget
that the civil war happened when you
take a statue of Robert Ely down
you're not saying well we're gonna
forget everything about the Civil War
all of a sudden no you don't learn
history from statues if you do you've
got a problem you learn history from
books and historians but this is about
are we as a society gonna say are we
about oneness wholeness and unity are we
about standing up for this where's it
where does this end where does this line
end it's like no that's the s illogical
fallacy it's been demonstrated many
times it's the argument from a slippery
slope and it doesn't apply to
this situation I don't want to get into
the argument but what I'm saying is that
I wanted to talk about this because I
don't think that it's an us-versus-them
issue I think it's a US issue I think
it's a whether you think that the
monument should be kept up but then
contextualized properly by like let's
put something on a plaque that says
exactly what these people stood for I'll
be open to that they don't have to be
torn down I'm not like if they're not
torn down I'm not happy but I also don't
think that as a white southern man who
used to seeing Hank Williams jr. if the
South woulda won we've had it made
loudly from link struck I don't think
I'm the best one to make the decision
about whether they should come down or
not because it's not my particular
situation that's being addressed here
it's like I think we should actually ask
our you know the black community what do
you guys think about this because you're
the ones that were dehumanized for
hundreds of years and then the South did
fight to for the right to continue to do
human human eyes you and hold you as
slaves so what do you guys think about
these monuments that would be a more
open perspective and attitude that I
think would ultimately bring about
oneness and wholeness in our country
which is what we need and that was when
I was talking to you earlier about this
whole overview effect which i think is
so pertinent to this mm-hmm
this is a term that's been around since
the 80s it's um it's something that's
been around since the first guy to go
into orbit but there's this thing called
the overview effect I actually want to
read it off of Wikipedia because it's
gonna be able to say it much better than
me what go read it off of my medium
account the overview effect is a
cognitive shift in awareness reported by
some astronauts and cosmonauts during
spaceflight often while viewing the
Earth from orbit or from the lunar
surface it refers to the experience of
seeing firsthand the reality of the
earth and space which is immediately
understood to be a tiny fragile ball of
life hanging in the void shielded and
nourished by a paper-thin atmosphere
from space national boundaries vanished
the conflicts that divide people become
less important and the need to create a
planetary
society with the United will to protect
this pale blue dot becomes both obvious
and imperative that is powerful it's
this is just takes people going up into
space and looking back down at the earth
and seeing that it doesn't look like a
map there are no borders
I don't wait what there are no borders
link that's just on a globe sucka and
seeing us as one species one group of
people we're all the same we're all
related we all come from the same place
and these stupid debates about
Confederate monuments and people getting
so freakin mad that they're willing to
drive a car into a group of people and
kill somebody seems so stupid when you
just take a step up or take a flight up
take a rocket ship up and look down and
see the full context of of our situation
actually I'm not trying to be divisive I
are divisive whichever way you say that
I mean I'm not trying to build a wall
build a wall right exactly I'd I'm the
last thing I think we need is a wall we
don't need a wall we need bridges and
I'm not talking about infrastructure we
shouldn't be I mean infrastructure is a
problem and I was a civil engineer I
know a lot about bridges but we need to
be I'd only been reading Mexico and the
bridges between people not walls between
people and and because do you feel like
given the conversation that happened in
the comments that did that prove really
being one of your first forays into this
type of thing our indications that that
happened or that it I mean it was still
was there's still a lot of arguments
busting out I was I mean if this was a
vlog on YouTube we know what the
comments would look like oh yeah they do
YouTube comments all right place you
didn't do that so in the what's the
assessment at this point overwhelming
support a lot like that's a bias support
right right right right so but what I
will say to you so it may be to fans of
yes okay in this particular atmosphere
that we're in right now standing
in saying what I said is not
particularly bold right I mean some
people are like oh this is so bold that
you stood up maybe we lost fans because
of it fans that I don't care - it's fine
if we lose them right but I actually
think that we probably in this
atmosphere right now the people who
watch our content I think we probably
gained more fans or there's people who
like well he's just they're just on the
west coast they're confused they're
they're leftist but they're still funny
so I'll let this one slide I mean he
don't know what he's talking about he's
just a comedian why does he think
there's that whole perspective that
happens but I didn't see a whole lot of
that what I saw there was cut there was
some there were people who just told me
that I miss it I missed the point or
whatever and I kind of engaged a little
bit at least on medium with a couple of
those people what I've learned is that
and I learned this a long time ago I
only engage with people whose initial
salvo is thoughtful it can be critical
and can be it can be in disagreement
with me but if it's not thoughtful and
constructive I'm not gonna get into a
conversation because I know that that
person is not interested in a
conversation like I had one guy on
Twitter who was like robert e lee didn't
support slavery and i was like okay
read this article from the atlantic
which clearly said shows that he did he
was a slave owner and he was actually
recorded as being a pretty harsh slave
owner and you know there's the thing
about well he was gonna fight for the
Union but he wanted to fight for the
south I'm not saying that Lincoln didn't
ask him to fight for the Union to leave
the Union but he was a slave holder and
he was in support of slavery and the
calls that whether he believed it or not
the cause that he was fighting for was
the cause of the Confederacy which was
to continue to have slaves which was a
state right yes but it was the only
state right that anybody care about all
that being said that guy read that
article and said hey thanks I didn't
know about this I can't believe he
responded that way but then I had a guy
on medium who was like gave me a
thoughtful response and and I kind of
gave him my thoughts back and he
basically he got oh he got a little
dismissive and basically told me I was
wrong but the thing that
there I did see a few people who are
like thanks for writing this I actually
think differently about this now
which that if one person feels
differently then it was worth my time
and then the other thing I saw is lots
of people I saw just people of color in
general kind of coming up and saying
thank you for writing this
thank you for someone in your position a
white dude in your position doesn't have
to say anything to this no one's
pressuring you no one's expecting you to
say anything standing up and saying this
thank you for that
what I what I will say is I didn't see
any people of color being like why would
you say this there's they're there that
that at least him in the in the in the
online world that I'm in that
perspective does not exist someone who
would disagree with that opinion he was
from that background but anyway you know
it's just what we we try to you know
what we try to do with our entertainment
in general is we try to create a place
where people can come and kind of forget
about all the stuff that's going down in
the world that brings people down and
there's so much of it today I agree it
is it's to create an environment where
we can build bridges where we as we as
humans can come together and at least
agree on let's have some fun with this
these guys are eating this thing that's
crazier yeah I mean our show is a
distraction right and that's why we
agree on that and that's why our show is
not going to become a play like I'm not
gonna first of all there was nothing
funny in my article at all it was just
serious right because I was like I'm not
writing this from a community
perspective our show for the most part
almost always is we're trying to be
funny we're trying to be a distraction
so we're not gonna bring these types of
opinions I'm not saying it's never going
to happen sometimes you just feel like I
gotta say something about something but
that's not the purpose of our show right
we're not Seth Meyers who like okay well
I'm gonna have a closer look where I'll
talk about Trump every couple of nights
it's like that's his that's what he's
doing that's his approach that
not typically what we do we're kind of
more of like the Jimmy Fallon approach
which even when he spoke about the
Charlottesville stuff he had like a
serious sort of monologue about the
Charlottesville stuff he was like this
is not a political show geumja is not a
political show we're not particularly
political people but when I think that
there's something that's not political
that is this is about humanity this is
just about humans getting along and this
really transcends political party and
affiliation those are the things that
we're gonna speak about when we feel
like something needs to be said and I
don't want to dismiss our show as being
just a distraction I think we hear from
a lot of people that for a lot of
reasons that it it meets you where you
are and gives you it doesn't just
distract you somehow it gives you hope
or energy to live your life it helps
yeah I mean distraction and the best
possible time right so it's I do believe
that our show and the heart the heart
behind it is to create bridges with
comedy you know it is kind of the same
thing the heart behind you running that
article was I just can't remain silent
on something but I want to do it in a
way that's that I want you wanted to try
your best to do it your way that didn't
build a wall that built the bridges yeah
and I think that's what I you know
that's what we want to do with our show
in general and it's not a cheap thing
just just to get what maybe it points
cheap laughs that's not it that's not a
cheap thing I think we appreciate the
fact that and hearing from them the
mythical beasts that it is a very
valuable thing well it's kind of the
same one of the things that's happened
in I think this has driven some
perspective change for us personally
just over the decade of doing this job
we haven't been in space okay so we have
not experienced the overview effect I
see where you're going now but what we
have done is we've built a fan base of
internet international it trained
sans borders via the internet we've
we've seen the pale blue dot and so like
just from humanity like 60 between 60
and 65 percent of our audience is based
in the US but that means that over a
third of our audience is outside of this
country and sometimes you just only see
things in this American political lens
and that becomes your life and you just
forget that you know there's people who
look at what's happening in our country
from the outsider like how can you guys
have come so far
how can you guys have done so much good
for the world but have so much discord
it's nuts it's so crazy how much hate in
division there is and we've seen people
you know it can be interesting like
we'll do something like I remember years
ago we did something where we just
thanked the American forces you know it
may have been Veterans Day or something
where we talked about and we'll continue
to do that we all knows holidays and
continue to thank our troops for their
service but what you see when you think
your troops for their service then all
of a sudden you've got somebody who has
a different perspective on your troops
and what your troops are up to you got
somebody in another country who's been
negatively affected by your troops and
to see these two guys that you look up
to like honoring the American troops is
like you're honoring the people who
murdered my dad you know I'm saying it's
like just just stopping and thinking
about that for a second whether or not
you think that every American war is
justified or not just stop and realize
that well for somebody whose family got
killed nothing none of that wasn't
justified and so but two or the
perspective our perspective has widened
quite a bit and even to bring it back to
a positive I think that I mean it's an
inspiring picture to think if all the
mythical beasts who watch any given
episode of good mythical morning
we're in a room together and you looked
and then you're you're mixed randomly
and you look to your left you look to
your right and I think I am proud of the
fact that I think a lot of people would
be shocked at who would who was right
there beside them and who oh you're a
mythical beast I'm I'm I'm a mythical
beast oh well you know it's I I think
that's ultimately what we're trying to
do with our show and it's uh is getting
everyone together physically in one
place and then we'll we'll say everyone
turn to your left and massage the person
I hate that don't you just hate it when
people now turn to the right
massage the shoulders to your right we
would never do that you see shoulder but
we but I still think the analogy holds
that if we were to do that and we're not
because the massage thing you look to
your right you look to your left not
because of the logistical problems
associated with it get to a point where
we're not shocked but we're elated that
we're all elated and it's like we're in
this together I you know I I have hope
that our show can does that yeah and you
know what and I don't think that that
Nina that or be a cosmonaut yeah you
know you can make a choice if you can do
that do that instead and I don't think
that that means that you lose your
ability to disagree this is another
thing that right is is it bothers me is
that there's just no room for
disagreement right now it's like
everyone disagrees but no one can have a
no one can have a civil discussion I
don't think it means that you lose your
political identity I don't think if
you're if you're a small government
pro-gun guy talking to a gun control big
central government person in your both
mythical beasts you can have a civil
discussion about what the merits of your
of your platform it doesn't in in you
should be able to do that and you
shouldn't write off either of those
people just based on the fact that you
find out that they believe that and you
shouldn't think that they want
something that's worse for humanity just
because you know you don't want to take
that small government pro-gun guy and
immediately throw him into the white
supremacist camp as if those two things
are remotely remotely similar and so I
just think that we're also trying to
just to demonstrate a civil discussion
and not getting mad not and not getting
not hurling personal insults not judging
people prejudging people I'm not saying
we're doing we're doing you know we're
just beginning to kind of talk about
this stuff but we just hope that that's
one of the things that's happening
throughout content too is that people
can come together and then when they do
disagree about something they can have a
civil discussion and realize that being
your mythical best involves having a
civil discussion where you realize that
your common humanity supersedes your
political religious ideology on that
note I do want to thank you guys for
being your mythical best in in the in
the the conversations that you guys have
with us the feedback you give us online
it's tremendously encouraging that
you've got big hearts so thanks for
being a part of the conversation hashtag
of your biscuits yeah will speak at you
next week this is the easy letdown
[Music]